الى ما جرى في هذا
الحاجز وتلك العمليه التي يقول بيان للجيش
الاسرائيلي انما نفذها كان مسلحا ما الذي
جرى هل من روايات اخرى تتحدث عما جرى في
حاجز بيت
فوريك نعم اعلن قبل قليل من قبل الجيش عن
استشهاد فلسطيني عند حاجز بيت فوريك حاول
تنفيذ عمليه اطلاق نار عند هذا الحاجز حيث
وصل هذا الشاب مشيا على الاقدام نحو هذا
الحاجز ويحمل سلاحا من طراز مسدس حاول
اطلاق النار صوب جنود الاحتلال لكن بحسب
بيان جيش الاحتلال فان الكتيبه
8109 للجيش الاحتياطي في جيش الاحتلال
قامت باطلاق النار صوب هذا الشاب بشكل
مباشر ما ادى الى تصفيته واستشهاده على
الفور هنا في محيط الحاجز حيث نرصد تواجد
او استمرار لتواجد جنود الاحتلال على هذا
الحاجز و عرقله لبعض لبعض مركبات
الفلسطينيين في الوصول الى منازلهم وتفتيش
بعض هذه المركبات ما جرى قبل حوالي ساعه
ونصف من الان شاب فلسطيني اقدم نحو هذا
الحاجز بحسب بيان جيش الاحتلال حاول اطلاق
النار ما ادى الى تصفيته بشكل مباشر بعد
ذلك منعت ايه منع الاحتلال مركبات الاسعاف
من محاوله انعاش الشاب او تقديم العلاج
الطبي له حتى تم تصفيته في الطريق ومنع
احد من الوصول اليه وصلت نجمه داوود
الحمراء في جيش الاحتلال نحو هذا الحاجز
وقامت بمصادره واخذ جثمان الشهيد الى
منطقه مجهوله ليتم الاعلان بشكل رسمي عن
استشهاده ووصول عدد الشهداء منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الى
300 وثلا 83 شهيدا بالضفه الغربيه المحتله
بواقع الاقتحامات المتواصله واعتداءات
المستوطنين ايضا بالتزامن مع هذه العمليه
ومحاوله اطلاق النار هناك اقتحامات
متواصله لمناطق عده في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله منها الخليل ومناطق الجنوب
وتحديدا مدينه نابلس حيث هناك تواجد
واقتحام لجيش الاحتلال الى بلده سبستيا
غرب المدينه وقام احتلال ويقوم في هذه
اللحظات باعمال تمشيط واسعه في اراضي
الفلسطينيين في محيط البلده ايضا في مدينه
جنين هناك اقتحام لبلده جلبون قضاء
المدينه ويقوم الاحتلال بنصب حاجز وا
اطلاق النار صوب منازل الفلسطينيين وبشكل
مباشر ايضا يقوم الاحتلال باعمال التفتيش
والترويع للاطفال في الطرقات في محيط
البلده هنا في حاجز بيت فورق استمر اغلاق
الحاجز لما يزيد عن ساعه في هذه المنطقه
منع الوصول او وصول الفلسطينيين الى
منازلهم هذا الحاجز يربط مناطق مناطق جنوب
نابلس تحديدا بلده بيت ففريق وبيت دجن
وشرق المدينه منع الاحتلال ويواصل
الاحتلال اغلاق الحواجز